for anybody listening who has kids or is
about to have kids if they're young my
belief now after raising four kids is um
gymnastics creates incredible body
awareness Incredible strength no risk of
injury you're not lifting weights you're
just using body weight becoming really
coordinated and then when they're like
seven eight years old I would put them
in every possible sport they would play
s eight Sports if they can everything
and I would do that for like 3 years now
they're 11 and 12 they're coordinated
you got a chance to see what sport they
excel at and then I would go all in and
in a perfect world if you have four kids
like me you put them all in the same
sport not because you want to take
anything away from any one of them but
because the family can't handle
effectively going in four different
directions every day just can't you just
can't do it everybody suffers a little
bit especially the parents